[Music]
we now have much more diverse workforces
than we used to in the old days okay
when they were mostly men for example in
that many women and and more white
people than people of color and so
here's a here's a question that you know
a little bit riskier but I think could
be an interesting one and that is for
people to think about ask the question
are we using all of the people resources
we have is is is everybody getting a
chance and you could do this at a
workshop you could be asking people to
think about whether the diversity we
have around the table whether enough
voices or all the voices are coming to
play for example it's not uncommon that
the larger the group the more men are
more apt to speak up than women
I don't know approach that by saying men
you should shut up more on women you
should talk out more but are we
accessing the voices the knowledge and
the energy and the wisdom of everybody
here so I was in a work setting as a
peer and people sort of looked at me as
a process person and I began to realize
at one point that the three women on the
team were not getting a lot of air time
and I just commented that hmm we seem to
have a kind of an imbalance in in who
speaking and I'm just inviting us to
consider to that as we go forward okay
wasn't putting anybody down the men
we're all making useful comments and it
wasn't that the anything wrong with the
women but that's an example of a process
comment you try to make neutrally and
descriptively and then I didn't end that
by saying okay Donna speak up okay it's
just and then what happened was there
was this sort of a tilting that occurred
because what I began to notice was that
when there was a instantaneous when
there gap opened up there was a man
mediately filling it
and that the that that some of the women
weren't like beating him to the punch
and so just that that little process
come in at the team it was an all-day
kind of retreat serve the purpose of
just some rebalancing with nobody being
the bad guy
[Music]